und in diesem moment kommen berichte
über massiven beschuss und massive
kämpfe in kiew verein wie schalten
direkt zu unseren beiden reportern die
dort in der ukrainischen hauptstadt sind
das ist paul ronzheimer und
peter hell können wir uns hören
paul befangen du bitte an berichtet
thomas wir sind hier auf der straße
richtung zentrum ungefähr zehn kilometer
vom zentrum entfernt
leider haben wir ein budget ein
kampfflugzeug hier am himmel gesehen was
sehr sehr tief geflogen ist in richtung
auch des zentrums der ukrainischen
hauptstadt und es sieht tatsächlich
danach aus dass hier jetzt die große
offensive gestartet ist das sieht man
auch daran an den fluchtbewegungen die
noch mal massiv zugenommen haben also
auf der straße raus aus ihrer
kilometerweit hunderte kilometer kann
man fast sagen also wir haben was 80
kilometer dort gesehen ein stau raus aus
der hauptstadt aus angst auf panik dass
jetzt die russischen truppen wirklich
komplett die stadt einnehmen könnten
peter hell ist für uns etwas zentraler
in kiew mit wie ist die situation bei
dir peter was kann zu berichten
ja ja wir haben ihnen jet in kampfbomber
jean paul rudd schrieb
natürlich
angegriffen die kosten sind direkt
eingegangen
dann soll es ungefähr fünf bis sechs
kilometern nur noch von hier entfernt im
osten schon zum schweren kämpfen
gekommen sein es gibt
maschinengewehrfeuer ist zu hören
gewesen wie wir von zeugen berichtet
haben wo irgendwie soll weiter wir sehen
diesen jet auch am himmel das sind
bilder die wir gerade sehen während
durchspricht
wir hören ihnen jetzt nicht sind
wahrscheinlich sehr hoch zu recht auch
wahrscheinlich wieder einbinden das
eingetroffen ist das ein russischer jet
heute von der ukrainischen luftwaffe vom
himmel runter geholt worden ist 24
werden die großen sehr vorsichtig sein
jetzt sind sie hier überhaupt über die
hauptstadt fliegen wollen ich möchte
noch mal sagen wir haben keine stacks
kilometer von hier mit schweren kämpfen
schwere kämpfe mit schusswaffen mit
maschinengewehren cetera das heißt ich
muss mich korrigieren nicht im westen im
osten dh
immer enger eingekreist und wir können
das überfliegen die stadt ist komplett
ausgestorben es sind kaum noch löschen
dann haben wir von einem kollegen gehört
dass einige bewohner sogar weiße flaggen
auf den balkon gehisst haben als sie
wollen sich gegeben dh dass im prinzip
ja schon truppen
die russische armee
peter wir von den dich sehr schlecht
daran dass du dass nico wirklich jetzt
zum und es ist auch sehr windig bei euch
wie wir sehen du bist jetzt raus aus dem
luftschutzbunker kannst uns berichten wo
die menschen gerade in kiew sich
aufhalten gibt es noch menschen die in
ihren wohnungen sind und die zivilisten
die wir auch eben bei dir im
luftschutzbunker gesehen haben die sind
ja nach wie vor auch dann dort in
sicherheit oder
die sind in sicherheit
pauli ja schon berichtet hat gerade
hunderttausende sind auf dem weg in den
westen versucht zu flüchten so schnell
es geht mit diesem werk diese
verkehrssituation zu lesen der rest
sitzt natürlich
untergebracht also
unterscheidet man
nicht hier kann rein kommen wird ist den
familien mit ihren kindern sind decken
ausgebreitet wenn wir nur die bilder
gleich nachreichen wir haben leider dort
kein empfang das längstens fünf dass
dort auch mit ihrer gegend und schlafen
dass wir
dritter ausgewandert danke peter noch
mal kurz paule und paula was ist deine
information und auch deine vermutungen
natürlich auch nicht alle informationen
sind ja klar wie wir das jetzt
weitergehen
du musst es sieht so aus dass die
schlägt albtraum szenarien die sich noch
vor wenigen tagen einigen wochen mal
ausmalen konnte war werden ähnliche
hauptstadt jetzt eingenommen werden
könnte von der russischen armee von
bloody mit polen und wenn ich hier diese
strikt aus aus der stadt die wir gerade
haben will
100.000 menschen auf der flucht in
richtung das für mich ein klares zeichen
dass die menschen große großes orga
haben und viele ausgehen dass die
ukrainische armee diese stadt nicht wird
halten können der weise wird es da noch
einen blutigen häuser immer wenn das
stimmt was ptl gesagt hat das weiße
flaggen teilweise an häusern hängen
sollten dann könnte es auch bedeuten
dass man versucht noch einmal in
irgendeiner weise das ist nicht zu
diesen dramatischen häuserkampf kommen
würde dieser war allerdings angekündigt
worden und politik kann man hat die
zivilisten dort auch bewaffnet hat die
eingestellt auf gegen die russiche und
jetzt kann man nur noch beten dass
keine wird es nicht treffen aber dass
wir
unter dieser unter diesem bombardement
zu leiden haben und das ist sich zu
viele opfer geben wird weiß man wo sich
die ukrainische regierung derzeit
befindet der ihren hauptsitz natürlich
in kiew hat es präsident selensky noch
dort nein dazu haben wir momentan keine
information besucht verschiedene berater
des polnischen präsidenten zu erreichen
natürlich kann man fast sagen sind sie
momentan nicht zu erreichen mit witali
klitschko dem bürgermeister der
ukrainischen hauptstadt habe ich zuletzt
heute vormittag 10 davon da hatte er
noch gesagt das an sich wäre vor der
stadt waren marie hören wir
ungefähr 10 km
im süden und die russischen truppen sind
offenbar
paul ronzheimer besten dank peter hell
in kiel für passt auf euch auf wir
bleiben in kontakt